[Music]
you look amazing you look amazing
well let's pretend that's true but I'm
talking about allies are on you right
now this hair first of all is it pops
it's like it's like a highlighter yeah
right it looks like you'd use it in a
textbook is it an actual highlighter
what did you do um I just colored it you
colored it black color yeah me and my
friends we sit around and do my hair
it's like a thing I want to be a rainbow
right I'm going through every color of
the rainbow with my hair except for red
you haven't done red are you avoiding
red for a reason why is that
okay I mean on you yeah thank you
no okay I'm cool it's cool it's cool as
we've established my hair sort of
Blondin out as I get older anyway yeah
I'm not the eye when I was a kid I had
orange orange orange yeah I'm not doing
orange either yeah it's for us okay
starting it yellow I'm trying I'm trying
so hard to find connection all right so
you're gonna keep trying trying
different things except that disgusting
horrible turn off that is red I'm gonna
talk about cats
I want to talk about cats well I know
that because I heard that you love cats
and it's something you and I haven't
talked about before and that your house
is kind of devoted to your cat's you
actually go out of your way to make your
cats more comfortable on your home cat
sanctuary they have their own room they
have their own couches like we have huge
balls of yarns that are obscene like I
had them custom made for my cats and I
don't know if you've heard but I'm
starting a cat cult a cat called yes I
didn't know about that yeah so you can
be in it and all you have to do is you
have to be a cat for me you may people
can join your cat cult yeah if they
themselves become a cat you have to like
like be a cat for me a Conan well okay I
mean okay why we have a cat anyone right
now I am they just like sit there and
they're [ __ ] you know
they did it this is my cat this is my
cat that mine doesn't do any this cat it
was a rescue
it found us it wandered into our house
and we started taking care of it and
just sits around we saved this cat's
life I know but it just sits around like
you know and you could give it food I
could give it gold and jewels and be
like let's go do you have a special
toilet for the cat's okay
in SkyMall they have this toilet for
your cat so you put litter on the toilet
and then your cat is supposed to go to
the bathroom in the toilet hmm yeah it
doesn't work you just said you love
SkyMall when I bought this thing loves I
buy onesies on SkyMall I don't know if
you like know about this but onesies are
very in right now our onesies in I
didn't know that yeah okay they are
Taurus yes well if that guy is wearing
him I've got to have one it's the same
thing a little baby wears yes that's
what you're wearing all the time okay I
didn't I didn't know this was a thing is
it a real thing with I don't know what
do you look at me for and there's like
little butt flaps and you can unbutton
no I don't worry about that just show
man talk about some penises listen that
was Aubrey Aubrey block brought that up
I asked her here's my question how was
your summer
look at the transcript how was your
summer became penis upon penises flying
around the room I think I got a similar
summer yeah bachelorette party yeah okay
[Applause]
you